welcome back to Hannity right before we  go all right the big surprise is quick  programming notes all right it's our  first week back in our old timeslot 90s  turn please tell your friends a special  huge lineup for you this week tomorrow  bill o'reilly will join us to talk about  the news of the day and his new book  Wednesday I travel to Washington holding  Washington accountable we have an  interview with House Speaker Paul Ryan  about President Trump Congress's agenda  the push for tax reform where are we  going to be on health care and then on  Thursday a rare interview I travel to  Florida and interview the one and only  Rush Limbaugh jam-packed week we hope  you'll join us unfortunately that's all  the time we have left this evening